l'attentât du drugstore saint-germain à
paris c'était le 15 septembre 74 une
grenade explose à l'intérieur du magasin
on relève deux morts et 34 blessés
principal accusé carlos de son vrai nom
ilitch ramirez sanchez
à cette époque il n'est pas encore
connue un an plus tard il prend en otage
les ministres du pétrole de l'opep
réunis à vienne
carlos devient alors la figure de proue
du terrorisme international
pendant vingt ans carlos multiplient les
attentats en europe
jusqu en août 94 quand il est arrêté au
soudan et ramener en france
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité en décembre 97 pour le triple
meurtre de la rue toullier carlos devait
encore répondre de cinq autres
accusations dont l'attentât du drugstore
saint-germain
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de paris a
accordé un non-lieu à carlos les juges
estiment que le dossier ne contient
aucune charge suffisante
un revers pour le juge antiterroriste
bruguière qui a instruit tout la faire
ce soir
l'un des avocats de carlos à lui une
première victoire de son client soit la
justice française de son côté
l'association sos attentats annonce son
intention de se pourvoir en cassation
une démarche adoptée également par le
parquet général de paris